[Music]
[Music]
alright not hopefully hopefully
everything is working so if anyone could
just confirm that we have audio and in
the video that'd be awesome and we are
we are off into checking checking the
games so I'm gonna just wait up for
everyone to join in and we're just gonna
pick a random game here maybe bye
what's that what's a nice handle brains
all right mr. brains is playing let's
check out a game by mr. brains better
para which positive a stomach or a
positive better alright seems to be
everything seems to be in order
hey Shahid Hassan yeah I don't I don't
really go live that often but now I kind
of do like every Friday we have this
tournaments and leeches hello panda
panda thanks for joining us are our good
moderator sir might yeah as usual the
links are in the description below
so both the links to the meadow arena in
the Friday arena positive is hamburger
Gaddafi positive eighty Jason what's up
well I'll tell you what's up we are
currently checking out the game between
mr. brains and mister smoking bird or
maybe it's an SS mockingbird a lot of
Bishop pure action going on here but
both players really enjoying their
bishops Khiladi Kumar hello sir hello
man Thank You Surya I was actually
planning for some some guests this
stream but I don't know if if we will
have any guests this stream but maybe
for the next one so I was I was trying
to make everything operational how to
add you know how to add the zoom call to
OBS and stuff like that never done that
before so was quite quite exciting
yeah it did the meadow arena started
first we have the meadow arena and then
we have the major tournament will I be
doing video on vicious game today I
don't know I don't know if I will be
doing it's today I already made one I
already made the Hari Krishna video that
was a really really fun game against for
Kakori but I will be publishing that one
after now after the stream but I'm gonna
check out some of the other games
probably tomorrow morning all matter is
okay Mary is just sleeping good they're
behind me like like a like a lazy
bastard am i into fantasy literature
yeah well depends on what you mean - am
i into it I am into it I just don't
don't read all that much or of anything
really at the moment but yeah if I had
the time I would be more than into it
and here we have a checkmate on the back
rank so Mockingbird takes the win
alright let's let's check out blindfold
chess all day alright we have blindfold
chess all day against mr. Jeremy and we
had some sort of a Scandinavian here all
right good stuff let's see let's see who
will prevail
do I like Eminem yeah I really enjoyed
them and when I was when I was younger
it was really really good stuff alright
let's see what's happening here
okay black black should be very happy
with what he got out of the Scandinavian
here as okay he did berserk so but he
still needs the developed pieces
yeah summer I know PU you got it man if
I could recommend one book for okay
here's a here's a plan that's a nice
plan a book for a chess beginner and I I
don't know I mean any book like really
any book any book will do just
fundamentals by capablanca is what I
usually tell people and then if they
enjoy it then they will grab another
book I guess
yes panda I'm also looking forward to
the 600 K video but first I I still
haven't still haven't picked the one I'm
gonna do as there's a there was so much
going on online these days and now
Magnus announced even another tournament
which will happen over the next week
thanks for the contribution CJ which
will happen on the next weekend I
believe and I don't know who's playing
I've seen I've seen Magnus's photo I've
seen Greece shook grips wife Katrina
Lucknow and I think I think dinara also
but I'm not sure what kind of eternity
will be I'm pretty sure it's gonna be a
blitz tournament do I know grandmaster
Bassam I mean yes I do
of course I think he he beat Geary yes
yesterday I believe in the in the
Nations Cup alright and oh that's gonna
hurt but maybe maybe he should have gone
for the rock instead but okay I don't
think it will be a problem
well obviously King f1 and now we go for
what yeah maybe it was better to go just
after rook it was it was cleaner
yeah reassess your chess is a great book
and appendices it well
what am i learning on guitar right now
well like I said I'm slowly slowly
getting back to playing guitar so right
now I'm I'm trying to do gambler by by
Johnny Cash so that's kind of bothering
myself with that and blind fall chest is
17 seconds whereas Jerry is on eight and
okay he's down a piece so I think
blindfold chest all day we'll we'll take
this one do I plan on making a video on
a really bad chess game I don't know
I like how bad like I do have I do have
one such game like it's a really bad
game like it's okay one player isn't
that bad but the other one is like
terrible and they are well super famous
but I decided not not to do a video on
it as I don't know it just seems like
it's too too bad of a game but maybe I
will maybe I will so we'll see
who is the least unconventional modern
player it's hard to say but there are so
many of course but on the absolute top
level probably probably in Yamanashi all
right let's check out okay again Jeremy
Wow that was totally totally an accident
use of 24 from Morocco again against
Jeremy most conventional who's the most
conventional chess player I don't know
I'd say I'd probably say I it's it's
hard to say like if you ask me maybe a
few few months back and maybe say
Khurana or dink but and now I I don't
think so anymore so I don't think there
are all that many conventional players
anymore at least at the absolute top
level everyone's doing some crazy allele
alpha stuff everyone's pushing the H
pawn you know it's it's crazy leave at
the water thanks for the contribution
man learn the bards song by Blind
Guardian it's easy to learn and an
amazing song by an even more amazing
band sleuth from Brazil man the bard
song by Blind Guardian okay it's fair
can an episode double check happen like
if you capture something up a song and
you deliver check and then let's say you
open up something else and you deliver
check yeah it can of course
like if pawn captures like it's a good
example like if there's a rook on the G
file and maybe yeah
or maybe no no it can't happen no sorry
I don't think a double-double a Poisson
check can happen please do bullet like I
do bullet you want you want bullet
tournaments or yes the tournament is
happening now like it's the same every
Friday every Friday meadow Arena the
smaller tournament starts at 7:00 p.m.
Central European Time and the main event
starts at 8:00 p.m. Central European
Time
so like that every week and every week
the the links are in the description
below
yeah we're gonna we can do some bullet
games after the stream will see a chess
game a day keeps the corona away there
we go all right let's see if if Jeremy
will will do better this game against
Yousuf 24 have I heard of the four owls
apparently they are big in creation no I
haven't alright and and now what white
is up the exchange so it's not gonna be
easy for for Jeremy
link takes you to safari and not the
leeches app well you probably don't have
a leeches app installed or maybe some
sort of an some sort of an Apple Apple
thing I don't know I have never used
Apple Shaun Jensen you want to be a mod
okay man
sure thing I don't know how many more do
we have today so yeah you can do it all
right one minute both and one player
upper rook that's the best no problem no
problem Sean Jensen use your powers
wisely
no I I often mentioned this but I don't
really watch football I like the only
time I watch football is every four
years like when there's a the world the
World Cup or is it the World
Championship then I watch some football
when like the Croatia is playing and
then everyone watches it so I watched as
well can you see the dog I'm pretty sure
you you can see the dog oh you're not
late we've basically just started and we
might have some guests but not sure and
I'm not sure if it's gonna work even if
we do get some guests since I've never
actually done that and still now now our
good friend Jeremy is down a night but
he's doing well on time so he might be
able to do this
hmm all right yeah I don't know how many
how many of you are actually playing on
on the computer and how many of you are
on phone since III almost never play on
phone and I imagine it's it's quite hard
when when time gets really low am i
drinking vodka
no it's it's just normal water but I'm
kind of thirsty today so I brought the
big bottle all right and it's gonna be a
flag off it seems like every blitz game
goes into into flag mode and wow wow
Jeremy is really pre moving that now
remove the king and he didn't remove the
King and he lost in time there you go
you have to pre move the king yeah it's
not what this is just normal rocky of
course all right we have five hundred
and thirty people in meadow arena let's
go okay let me can check out who is who
is leading the tournament just world one
six one two and berserk king everyone
okay we can check out one game by the
leader but not now as the game is almost
over
so we're gonna go some somewhere else
let's say here and all gambito or
gambito are you playing a game no who's
this Kevin along with not playing
maxxium all right Maxie no let's check
out the maximum game
for those of you who are saying you
can't enter the tournament it's because
you are higher rated than 17-hundred so
if you were even if you were just fire
rated yesterday than 1700 and then lost
rating today you still will not be able
to enter it's sort of a sort of a safety
mechanism to to prevent Smurfs from
entering well not actually to prevent
them but to make it more difficult for
them to enter so they don't ruin the fun
for everyone else who is actually lower
rated and wants to fight for some of the
top places positive Krishna
thanks for joining man can online just
be considered esports well I don't know
it chess is considered a sport and well
if you play it online it does doesn't
make sense that it's an eSport I mean if
League of Legends is an eSport then I I
don't see why why chess wouldn't be so
yes yes Philip you are correct I'm from
Cluj oxi
I still haven't seen I know what
happened in the vidiians game against
the eleven but I still haven't seen the
game was it was it a good game captures
captures probably he will also sacrifice
the night and then go for what exactly
probably look here after Queen captures
of course
so Queen captures and now first this I
guess
ok now you now you just made it a little
bit easier I guess for some further up
the board or that yeah that also works
haha nice totally missed that one that's
what you get very nice congratulations
man Joker in chess alright we need one
that's like starting we don't want one
that's already in the endgame
Joey lemon bra okay Phillip extreme D no
one's game is just starting out okay
this one is just starting out
yeah I've played League of played league
more than I the more than I you know I
think anyone should but not I don't
anymore
it's well I mentioned it too many times
basically it's just not not the game I
once enjoyed where will your podcast be
available on youtube or obviously but
we're gonna publish it on some other
other platforms as well you're just
gonna have to check which one's the
chest guy you want to be a moderator
okay man
there you go you are a moderator but
that's it we know we need no more
moderators maybe if if things get really
crazy we can do it but yeah sure thing
man
while we have so many mods but that's
that's okay the more mod we have the the
the better the experiences yes welcome
to more gang Thank You SK 17 thanks a
lot man all right
what is happening here we had another
Scandinavian and here black is doing
good good progress
okay that's oh there was a free pawn I
guess but it's even better now
now it's but now night here hmm maybe
the pawn was better or maybe not we'll
see it's for them to figure it out and
for us to enjoy
can I please show games further up the
board yeah I will when the tournament
near gets and you know closer to the end
what just happened here okay he decided
to go for that
sure
was visit versus 11 dead good I haven't
seen the game
I saw the Hari Krishna game and I was
very happy with that one and black up a
night okay
[Music]
but now the night is trapped this is
just weird
yeah this is very weird but okay black
will have a lot of time picking up the
pawns so still still should be winning
how the Krishna game was heartbreaking I
mean the one against Jorge quarry I
don't know which one which one do you
mean
how many monitors are in front of me
only - only - III I'd go for a third one
but my desk is just too small for that
but a third one would do would do nicely
yeah can I continue the Murphy saga I
can but I'm not going to just yet as the
Murphy saga amorphous games aren't going
anywhere and as long as there's
something happening today we're gonna
cover that first how am i doing today
well today actually pretty great it's
been a while since I've continued on my
Final Fantasy 7 remake quest as like I
said I don't I don't play all that much
of anything these days and I said I'm
gonna I'm gonna play through that one
since I said it is my favorite game the
original and today I got in some
hour-and-a-half of playing in the
morning so I was very happy about that
but I'm still basically at the beginning
soul
and white is down everything black has
to okay it's checkmate I thought it was
gonna be another flag off but the good
game calving Elango alright we still
have 25 more minutes into the tournament
619 players alright to lend crowley's
here is he playing ok let's check it out
let's check out lens game what's this he
goes for the French all right yes Bruno
the the questions for mvl can still be
sent like whenever since it's it's it's
in a week so you can still submit
questions yeah why do engines sometimes
fail to find winning moves the humans
see well they don't they just need more
depth and then then they're gonna find
it so it's not not that they don't see
it they just need a bit more time yeah
or is he pulling up his socks alright
so black needs to figure out what's
happening here and how he will develop
but as he's playing the French it's
pretty normal but when you play the
French you always have to figure us
things out Thank You Chandra thanks a
lot man yes Blake says it says it will
use the links in the description
whenever you feel lost or you know that
maybe maybe you should improve your day
or something there are always links in
the description
yeah black is up a piece so he will
develop eventually unless he won't
that's that's always a problem we'll see
all right white is really mounting up an
attack black needs to find a way to to
consolidate and enjoy his extra piece f4
g5 is now coming and black steel still
still
it's gonna be hard it's gonna be tough
for black huh goes after the bishop okay
he was able to get that Knight to f3
goes after the rook
he will eliminate two one of the one of
the attackers and now f5 opens up this
and maybe black did it yeah he did g5
yeah maybe maybe not capture on g5 now
captures and now white will go for
something like this it's gonna be gonna
be tough maybe black to play g6 now to
stop everything
maybe we'll see
okay he decided for b6 instead so he's
not afraid of this attack okay I I think
I think black should have gone for four
g6 but it was it was tough sake white
sacrificed well well maybe not to anot
well for perfect play but well enough
Bishop g5 with check okay he's gonna
give up the Queen to stay in the game
yeah but now it's a queen against the
rook okay Lynn Lynn hanging on in there
that's that's the spirit
and it's made okay
good game it was a tough tough game to
defend let's see who do we have here
psycho 1997 alright let's see
psycho 97 against Eric Hawkins from USA
that mate took too long
okay what's happening here these guys
are really really fast as they've traded
everything off and there goes the bishop
or he's gonna go for that first yeah
makes sense now you grab the bishop and
we we have a really quick game here so
we almost missed it
yes controlling the center is a vital
part of chess openings like you know he
who controls the center wins the game
that's how it goes you control it either
with the pieces or with the pawns huh
yeah black black is not getting out of
this one
have I met Anand
yeah I've met him I met him in Zagreb
last year during the Grantchester in
Croatia when everyone will visit it got
my chessboard signed and everything no
wish you can see that wish is crushing
everyone okay we have a Jose Raul here
Oh again against the land crowd
unbelievable
okay let's see if Lincoln can do do
something against the hose arrow kappa
kappa negra so everything equal equal
material but it's bishop against the
night so we'll see
jelena is not playing this one maybe
she'll play the next one we'll see
okay so we've traded off a pair of rooks
and now black wants to trade more and
now it's a bishop okay he trades that
and for some reason white doesn't
capture with the night it's uh it's a
bit weird but okay Jose Raul knows best
where does Adam live who who's Adam why
not covering all of Nations Cup Willam I
decided to take take a little break
after the Magnus Invitational that was
pretty brutal no rest days no nothing
and then this just starts right the day
after so III will cover some of the
games maybe two per day but not not all
of them obviously entertainer no I'm not
married but it's it's as if I am since
so we've been living together for like
seven years now so pretty much the same
thing
what does a good matter mean that still
is still a mystery
nothing nothing's changed from the last
week stream his Magnus really greedy not
that I know of no he even he even likes
giving away money all right 99 checks
King goes back and ya still still
understand why white capture with this
instead of the night I'm but okay now
the the king can enter the position if
yeah but you can't really denied we'll
just kick it back okay
black making some progress black
definitely making progress he grabbed
the pawn and now he grabs this one and
then he pushes pushes some of the pawns
makes sense
no that's not paranormal activity when
the TV starts by itself that's just I
don't know what it is it's just it can
happen so it happens I guess is there a
game called Carlson's immortal I don't
think so I think he's still too young to
have any mortal game like it's hard hard
to say doing well die with job doing
well how you doing man thanks for
joining us
does Maeda sleep a lot yeah but he's
very old so it makes sense for him to
sleep a lot
all right let's see if Len can do this
he controls b3 and he's definitely gonna
push that pawn followed by let's say
Knight e3 check and then the King just
helps out here and now now the pawn can
be pushed very nice Knight checks you
make your way with the King or do you
yeah you do
okay so now White's gonna harass you
with some checks from behind but now you
shift your attention to the to the King
side and that's that's just that just it
okay there's no reason to give that away
I guess but yeah this should be should
be over now if if white doesn't harass
you too much you go here you go here and
that's that yes meadow means fear in
Portuguese that's true
and now it's it's over
quick quick jump with the night and whoa
where is that night going okay he wants
to do it like this that'll work
oh yeah summer summer Opie and
black-flagged white so congratulations
land good game good game let's see how
our leaders are doing chess world
against and new era is here also again
without a single loss and again with a
very low rating so that's a new account
for the new era who seemingly makes new
accounts for every tournament we make
but yeah it's you know for fun so yeah
should have gone for me but okay you
know it's when it's flying time is
flying the time there is no way around
it I've got matter means great chess
youtuber in all languages well sets or
well said and here we have a game since
there is no way to defend against this
you cannot block since everything covers
this square good game by chess world
very nicely done new era catching up
alright let's let's check out but we've
seen a lot of his games in the previous
tournament so let's see aniket let's see
how aniket is doing again against I'm
not stop fish now that you say you're
not stock fish that's already very
suspicious
how did I get them be able to be the
first guest on my podcast well I sent
him an email and I didn't think anyone
would respond at least not very quickly
and I was already preparing emails for
some other guests but then I immediately
got a reply so I haven't even sent any
emails twenty-one other than him so
basically was a I I sent it and he
accepted and that's just it favorite
towel sacrifice 9f for against the
protein ik in their World Chess
Championship match game game six that
that one's just a monstrosity alright
that was a there was a brave phone grab
now that the Queen moves even route
captures and g7 is an idea we just wind
the Queen okay he doesn't want it he
wants the rook but captures and then
like here wins the Queen but now you
will win the rook as there's the maid
threat so I guess that that also works
do I do I have a viewer from each from
every country I do believe so but I
don't think there's like a way for to
actually check that is it possible to
have more Fischer games in the future
yeah it is we've covered the Bobby
Fischer saga with you know his complete
streak from the palma de mallorca
inter-zonal to the candidates matches to
the match against Spassky but we will
cover some of his games like maybe 1958
United States Championship or 59 or
tournaments like that that we we haven't
really covered we've covered some nicer
games but not like the tournament in its
entirety
no I've never met Ben Feingold of course
know who Ben is but I've never met him
but I've never met most people since I'm
from Croatia lots of viewers in Sudan
we're very happy to hear that and I'm
not stuck with wins congratulations
mister I'm not stop fish let's see
what's happening at the top and first
lost for chess world by new era so a new
era really just destroying everyone and
blindfold chess all day also but just
world got in the most games so we'll see
if the flame will be able to overcome
the number of games also night killer
one two three we haven't seen his game
without a loss so far playing alone
artists 2000
what do you think chat who who do you
pick Casper over or Karpov whenever
whenever someone asks me that question
in the chat I just shifted over to the
chat and here we have a nice nice fork
that dark square Bishop is maybe a
little bit annoying but you're okay
hahaha first with check excellent
excellent
so now to whites totally miss that
yeah I don't have a preference when it
comes to Messi or Ronaldo but as I don't
really watch football at all especially
especially not the football where they
play but I don't know it just it just
seems like Messi would be more more of a
kind of guy that that I would enjoy
hanging out with maybe how popular is
chess in Croatia very very popular
getting more popular by the day you know
things are happening Kasparov is here
and now Karpov is opening up an Academy
in the rear cards it's gonna be wild
no not very often sometimes I will watch
maybe a tennis match but again very very
rarely
thank you thank you shanton thanks man
how popular is cricket in Croatia I
don't think it's it is I don't think
it's popular at all and will we see a
checkmate here like G nope he's gonna go
for the pawn so we'll see up to pieces
black will win but we'll just have to
see how bone bone bone amps you are ho
several Kappa [ __ ] now you played well
you played well yeah I mean we can show
everyone's game but we're gonna show as
many as we can
thank you Jim 32 thanks man
alright and chess world wins so let's
see if anything changes at the top so
basically if if chess world that doesn't
get paired with new era or blindfold
chess all day and continues to win I
think we have our winner but you never
know maybe maybe these guys can get some
really really quick wins in okay this
game just started so let's check it out
what was this there was a car conned
wishes best game till today ah there are
too many to choose from I don't know but
he okay against our engine in 2013 Tata
Steel that's an obvious pick but also I
think it's game nine against Kasparov in
their match 1995 really really wild
stuff favorite Pokemon I don't know I
don't think I have a favorite one
like maybe maybe Snorlax I don't know do
I enjoy playing caro-kann no III think I
tried it like I thought maybe maybe I
maybe I'm I could be a car account
player but I couldn't it was just bad ok
so that's a free Bishop no yeah you get
the check and ok so it was a it was a
blunder
my opinion on the Queen's Indian defense
I don't I've never played it I played it
once in an over the board game I did
okay it was I think it's a reasonable
opening but ever since alpha0 kind of
refuted it people are reluctant to play
it okay black is down a bishop but he
will he will try and trick white however
he can he's already considering some
nasty stuff with rook captures as other
than that I don't think black has ways
of playing this not okay maybe if white
gives back some material the knight
attack yes the knight attack obviously
you have to play that it's the best all
right what what now white give that F
pawn for some reason yeah there we go
I said he was going for that now he's
gonna push the pawn and win the game
good stuff good stuff
and come to YouTube thanks man and now
King seated there's no other move yeah
there is no other move I'm drinking just
plain water yeah I block that pawn
that's the stuff
how'd it go away thanks man my rating in
classical it's around twenty one hundred
and something something little 2100 and
maybe ten currently
will I watch Tony Ferguson versus Justin
MMA fight
I don't know i-i've been following some
MMA when it was that normal Meadowvale
vs mcgregor fight and then mcgregor lost
and then he had one fight where he kind
of came back and then he wanted to
rematch but it was about then that i
stopped really stopped following so i
know where where the MMA world is
currently at but i'm pretty sure there
are a lot of those to follow up on did I
watch Burn Notice I don't know what that
is man play a match against MV oh yeah I
was actually thinking to finish off
every podcast with a game or maybe like
a three-minute blitz game so yeah maybe
maybe we'll get a an Argand matter in VL
game so I have to prepare some some
night off logical thinker yeah you can
still send questions for the podcast and
black is not giving this up he's very
persistent but I don't think it will it
will matter but yeah this is these are
the moments where you have to be the
most careful you you have everything but
you are very low on time and okay just
go after that pone nothing other than
that matters
it's almost as if white white is the one
who is defending here and that's a queen
very nice black will try to try to grab
a stalemate huh ma teach there's always
next time but there's also the other
tournament the Italian opening it's the
best because it's the only opening that
leads to the Evans gambit so yeah and
finally we have resignation just world
wins good game man and how are we doing
okay 14 seconds left in this tournament
so we are finished with the meadow arena
well we're just gonna wait those five
seconds to see if everything straightens
out
dubov would do is an incredibly creative
player really really a great great
player
well obviously it's a great player but
he's just
there's someone nicknamed haha good Matt
or two all right so the middle arena
ended and we have our winners
I just world one six one two no era 1000
and English drunken Stein's so not a
Norwegian one like the the world
champion but in English
drunken Stein then we have a blindfold
chess all day in four place a vector
cause in fifth Ivan Madar the second
Oregon at of two in sixth ninth killer a
night killer one two three so a lotta
nights died today obviously and she's
psycho X I I guess crusher Oni squad in
ninth and we have I'm not stock fish in
ten obviously if you stock fish I'm
pretty sure he would be first but yeah
that's it for the meadow arena now we're
gonna publish that later on on the
social media so make sure to
congratulate everyone and Hagen matters
Friday arena starts in nine minutes we
have seven hundred and seventy three
players registered so far so for those
of you who are interested in joining in
there is a link in the description just
click on it it says join Friday arena
here and you can just start the
tournament these are the top ten players
so top seed vs 99 from United States
feed a master then a th four four one
Aladin 13 a mrs saab in fourth Nick
Spiro Bruno Popovich along in 26 1995 we
have Baron starker and Lord Davos from
Game of Thrones
obviously Thank You KH and good evening
good evening to you all right we have
eight minutes so we we have time for for
a game if anyone sent a challenge
okay here we have one
let me just switch that over to the next
tab so I don't lose tabs all right
templates all right let's do this and he
goes for d4 very nice let's see if we
can get something here we're gonna go
for check and let's go
h5 a5 let's go back or let's capture
even better let's go for some trades and
let's go d5 let's go let's go c5
how long did my classical game go I
don't know
it's pretty long I guess like maybe six
hours sounds about right
you saw an illness Facebook that your
Zara was with Kasparov where was that
taken that was taken in Capri minutes
during the Renaissance Fair in Capri
Mesa when Kasparov visited as Paris was
having an simultaneous exhibition and
well we all just came to check up on how
they're doing okay so what was my plan
in giving up the c5 pawn I didn't really
have any so let's just continue
developing if he goes Knight here to
defend it yeah okay I'm gonna grab that
with the night and okay
let's go here so I'm down a pawn and I
don't have any any good reasons to be
down upon so we're gonna have to figure
something out who will be the next world
champion it's hard to say maybe maybe
someone who is not even qualified to
play it let's go here maybe someone who
is not even even in the big picture KH
will I publish more alpha0 games if I
have them probably yeah okay where is
the knight going probably here but I
kind of don't mind that let's go let's
put that pawn all right both getting
very long time yeah I guess I'm gonna
grab that it opens up this but I also
don't have to worry about the b7 point
anymore so let's just go here and after
the Knight moves maybe then we can
harass the Queen a bit this is nicely
protected I can maybe get okay he just
gave me the night he was doing really
well up until this point or I'm missing
something
yeah he just yeah he just gave me a
piece that's it's a shame and I don't
think he has anything to show for it
yeah it's a pretty bad pretty bad deal
let's go here
okay he wants the trade here yeah I
guess we'll trade and also just make
some room for our king so I don't
blunder any mates how do you join the
tournament well you click on the link in
the description and Carla no no I said
Moorish dude
don't be weird man okay so yeah I have
to be careful I just don't want to allow
anything like this I am up a piece but
still so let's try and get something
going yeah let's let's get our rook into
the game again oh but then he's just
gonna go here I have to bring back the
Queen that's pretty lame and also I'm
down to 28 seconds Wow that's sad
let's go here some pressure pressure the
Queen a bit
yeah that's free Queen thank you for
that I have to play a bit quicker okay
he resigns good game man
that was he was he was better I didn't
really need to give up that pawn but any
bullets challenges we we have time for
one bullet all right we have English
drunken Stein with a bullet challenge we
got time for a bullet before the
tournament starts all right let's let's
go hopefully my my set up can I can take
streaming while playing bullet at the
same time okay another free pawn but we
already gave up one point in the
previous game so not not a problem okay
he still doesn't want to capture here
okay
we're gonna have to shift our
dark-squared bishop somewhere else as
here it's just ugly okay man you're
gonna go you're going over
all right to go after the night and now
he's gonna go here and we have to we
have to get our Bishop out of here yeah
let's go here see what he captures yeah
he's gonna go for that
yeah I kinda have to take this and now I
lose here okay yeah okay I have to give
up this pawn but it's okay yeah let's go
here double up here I guess make it
safer bring the Queen in yeah not not
all the way I guess
yeah like yes okay maybe we can get some
Bishop to e5 in yeah he's gonna trade of
course so we're gonna have a nice flag
off here yeah it's with checks so of
course he doesn't mind let's get the
rook in yeah let's push the pawn all the
way go here let's check him some phones
grab some phones grab all the phones
yeah let's go here all right no you
don't thank you all right
Sumeet ah there was a weird mate
okay good game man that was fun okay now
I need the link for the main event as
our tournament is starting so it's a
good thing I have it in the description
below all right
and we're off
let's see alright first we're gonna
check up on our game from someone from
the top 10 model Eevee from Slovenia is
here
all right let's see against the Knicks
pyro 13
[Music]
what to recapture with all right yeah I
kind of guess you don't want to push a 5
here yeah you want to push these 6 and
nicely developed and that's it loans you
need the link to the tournament the link
to the tournament is in the description
as usual do I like the song stargazer
from the band rainbow I don't know maybe
I I know it but not by name
do I still get my heart beat up when I'm
in the last ten seconds of course if
it's if it's a tough game and I really
want to win then of course yeah
when will I show the Morphy saga now
when we finish everything that's
happening in the in the current world
which might not be possible as a lot of
things are happening today so black is
stuck guarding the backwards d6 pawn and
he pushes it to d5 okay which is not
great as white will most likely do
something else okay I thought he would
push e5 but dogged Kimura thanks man
thanks for contribution
nor Lou who is who is your boy Dean from
Croatia guitar or piano
I prefer piano but i-i've never I mean I
I played it a little bit but it's
obviously a lot more difficult but I
will enjoy when someone plays it well
all right
so black got rid of his backwards pawn
and now he needs to figure out what to
do with it
yeah now capture the bishop maybe or not
maybe maybe black blunders if he
captures the Queen then grab the bishop
first but of course black will not
blunder that and now just win back your
pawn I guess yeah okay so it's black
happy here I guess he's happier than he
was yeah he has to worry about the the C
coupon but yeah now the rook can get
into the game it's gonna be a fun game
and in his prime or Magnus in his prime
well we still we still don't know did
Magnus reach his prime maybe maybe
Carlson's prime is yet to come
who knows
[Music]
who is the other person whose picture
appears in the live feed besides me I
will I will let the chat answer that if
you guys know who who this guy is I know
if I'm pointing in the right direction
but yeah I am alright
we have rugby eight and now what's
happening with that night
white grab the pawn yes Chet knows Chet
Chet says it well alright he's gonna
grab that give up the b2 pawn yeah black
doesn't really want to give up that dark
square bishop but you don't want to be
down a pony torso okay what's queen
there you go after the a6 pawn and we're
gonna have a flag off I'm pretty sure
it's gonna go down to that David Kimora
no you're not seeing the dog behind me
since meadow is now sleeping on the
floor he likes to he likes to mix it up
yeah you can measure the delay with that
question that is true I also thought of
that exactly in that moment the man is
most intelligent at 28 years old I don't
I kind of don't think that's true or if
that's like a scientific fact then you
know disregard would have just said
future of perugia yeah I think he has a
very bright future if he continues
playing chess that was a freebie shop
white is not interested in a free Bishop
and freedom master Marv levy gets
flagged all right good
named Nick Spiro 13 let's see go some of
the players from from the other side of
the of the tournament who are maybe just
starting out all right
Kajal AHA cadres here is a colleague
from from my chess club all right let's
see how he how he does this game always
in the end game let's see how he how he
goes about it
when is the chess manga coming very very
soon like it's almost here we are
finishing up chapter 1 as we speak well
maybe not as we speak but every day it's
closer to completion what do I do for a
living I make videos on stuff mostly
chess and here we have a nice draw
alright Kizer he rock versus cargo ends
in a draw let's check out some other
guys let's see who is playing Queen
riders alright let's let's go for this
one any thoughts of streaming in twitch
yeah I don't know I I just everything
seems to be working fine on YouTube so I
don't know why I would switch to twitch
but maybe if I'll be streaming something
else like maybe something other than
chess maybe I can use twitch for that I
don't know which country am i from
Croatia I'm from Croatia Dallas are over
we already had a tile saga
maybe I should redo it like I should
redo the tile saga only in 60 frames per
second and and High Definition
Brandon you noticed I don't have ads in
my videos yeah I do have ads I just
don't allow mineral ads so if the video
already started then I don't allow ads
but if if an ad is to show up before the
video then I allow that but I don't
allow it in the middle since that's what
I hate the most when someone else does
it like you know I watch something and
then then the ad comes up that's just
the worst is Fabiano Italian I I don't
think so I think he's like born and
raised in Brooklyn and then he lived in
Italy but then I mean I don't think he's
actually Italian pretty sure he's not
to have more news about the Magnus drama
no not not at the moment he's grown
aldino playing I don't know I will check
after the match you can never know if
he's playing sometimes he says you'll
play and then he doesn't and then
sometimes he just shows up without
mentioning it it's hard to say
have I ever worked somewhere yes I've
actually worked quite quite a lot of
places in quite quite different jobs no
I've never visited Ireland but I do hope
to visit it one day when it's not rainy
what are my thoughts on the GU Keys I
don't know what's a GU key
have I ever met Magnus I've seen him in
person when I went to London for the
World Championship and I've met him in
Croatia last year when I went they were
all playing the the Grantchester in
Zagreb in Croatia so everyone was there
so i if you remember I got that
chessboard signed by everyone except
Wesley so I was missing one signature so
instead I came to cross his father
Henrik and I told him that maybe he
could sign it since I'm missing one
signature and he's he said yeah sure and
then he signed it and now I have like
every member of the 20 2019 Grantchester
who signed my board along with Coulson's
cross his dad and we have a nice mate on
h7 by her be to God
so congratulations her be all right
let's see Simon
those are some weird names let's look
for a really really weird name Eric
Hawkins mad cat
all right mad cat what's mad cat up to
against Willy Wonka all right mad cat
versus Willy Wonka okay that point is
not not going to d4 that's definitely
you can't find the podcast anywhere
since it's not it's not available yet it
will only be made on the 14th and then
published maybe around 16th to 20th
I still haven't I still haven't watched
Joe Rogan's podcast with with the new
Elon Musk podcast if any of you have
seen it is it is it good I think he
published it yesterday
do I think Vincent Kaymer will reach the
world top well if anyone can it's it's
definitely Vincent he has been a Peter
Lego as his coach so I don't know if
that doesn't help then then it's not
your you know it's not your year alright
so he had to trade there since he's
either getting checkmated or something
we were is going to happen Harshita Raja
Ron namaste from India thank you a lot
man and we have King goes up the board
and that's it's not made since the
bishop is cut off but if the bishop was
controlling that it would be so how do
you open it up no I do not conduct an
online chess class I do make some videos
and me maybe if you if you call that an
online chess class III wouldn't but yeah
other than that not really good precinct
Ozzy thanks a lot man thanks for a
contribution
I'm the reason your friends think twice
before challenging you oh that means
that I ruined your relationship with
your friends now they play against
everyone except against you Claudia
wants to be a mod because you want your
nickname to be blue I know you can't be
a mod for those reasons mod reasons have
to be pure unless you have a pure reason
to be a mod I don't know
thanks a lot mr. Otto although even musk
said neuro-link within a year all right
I'm gonna check it out it's the this
time it's two hours longer I think their
previous podcast was like three hours
long so you really have to prepare for
it
qualia with Sequoia how is called a
doing yeah you did saga definitely and
we just logged in and there goes the
Queen oh man Korra it's not your day
yeah and he resigns yeah I was a that
was to be expected all right
Farah not I know the bad bishop all
right what's happening here with the bad
bishop against the chena tan shop Aria
the chena Township Aria I don't have a
favorite football team I can't remember
who III did play a few games of Pro
Evolution Soccer against the Ellen on
the other day and I I had one team I
just don't know which one it was I think
it was a Russian team
[Music]
yeah Croatia is I guess pretty good at
football yeah I didn't watch the World
Cup when Croatia got to the finals no
it's not vodka
where does everyone think it's vodka if
it be anything it'd be rakia it wouldn't
be vodka all right
so white king is well over all the way
there but black king isn't doing that
great either but if Black gets in this
mate then okay so you block it that way
and how do you continue okay makes sense
oh yeah you had to do that thanks a lot
Danielle College 80 I don't know I feel
a nice blink
no she's not playing ah Louise you are
here since the Bobby Fischer saga oh so
you've been here for quite a while how
to memorize chess coordinates you just
speak them out loud and you think about
them very often and then it just happens
then all of a sudden you play blind for
chess without without a problem
all right King and pawn and game with
black completely winning can he do it
now he pushes the pawn and that's it
[Music]
Nik katrell yeah I will be continuing it
but now we've switched over to the
morphe saga and well I don't know when
we'll be doing a lien saga but it's it's
definitely gonna be done well at some
point it's also gonna be a pretty big
saga Donkey Kong with a C then you guys
play Donkey Kong I played a lot of
Donkey Kong all right here we have let's
see alpha megalithic Alpha Omega lyric
against the conga who will I accept
challenges after the tournament I don't
know since it's ago it's gonna be over
three hours when the tournament finishes
we'll see if I'm not gonna be too tired
then yes if I'm gonna be tired and
probably not better save it for a stream
that's just gonna be the challenges what
is the chess manga that is an excellent
question
it's a manga that's currently being
created in absolute secrecy and it's
gonna be awesome
it's gonna be a lot of chess in there
but a lot of other very very interesting
guess stuff like you know some AI robots
not gonna disclose too much but it's
gonna be pretty fun can I explain the
Magnus drama well no not really
that's why I said that when I will no
more than I will I will give you more
information there is no drama it's just
someone says this he says that and you
know yeah Craig Craig RK 84 sorry about
that
thanks a lot man
[Laughter]
yeah it's not it's not actually game
against Carlson it's a game against
Carlson and osseous a hand and brain
game which I totally totally sucked at
really you need we need more mods marco
says we need more mods all right does
anyone does anyone want to be a mod we
will accept one mod maybe it will
improve our it will improve our chat all
right I'm checking for someone with a
boss and scheme alert alright man you
are you are a moderator there you go man
we're gonna go with one now and then
maybe maybe more after that all right
although megalithic a down to 19 seconds
and what's happening here the rook is
under attack and that passed pawn so we
are going to have a nice flag off okay
yeah you can't you can't check the King
or maybe you can move faster check
yeah check look here and then bring the
pawn in strike dinner for you and the
dog thanks a lot man I'm pretty sure
that's a steak but either way thanks a
lot dr. Kimura I think yeah I think we
have a plenty of mods now unless our
mods think differently all right let's
see a few more from from deep within and
then we're gonna check out what's
happening in the in the top all right
funny number
thanks a lot mr. potato bushes yeah it
is a funny number Phillip Mema says why
he can't find the the arena in Mobile I
don't know everyone always asked this
question I've never I don't really use
it on mobile other than maybe for for
doing some puzzles or challenges so
haven't really thought about that also I
was thinking maybe of doing some streams
of just doing the solving puzzles might
be a bit interesting maybe I could even
convince myself to try and do them might
take it a bit more seriously if I did it
on stream
[Music]
all right India since everyone is asking
that it's still not too late to submit
questions for nvl since the podcast is
only only on the 14th so yeah you can
still submit questions any dreams
playing in this one no I don't think
they are all right so do we go after the
pawn or do we not go after the pawn yeah
obviously not since you lose a rook the
yeah I saw Heidi Krishna's match I even
made a video on it but I still haven't
published it I will publish it right
after the stream so yeah it's it's it's
pretty great all right so maybe we shift
our attention over to here and maybe
somehow start pushing those pawns we
want to start attacking and the king and
the queen side before why it starts the
attack on the Kings side why India is
losing is weighted so bad well he did
have a tough break he lost some three or
maybe four games in a row but he his
luck turned now as I saw he did he did a
good job in hand in last round
any plans for calling grandmasters to
celebrate milestones yeah I'm currently
in the in the business of trying to get
my zoom call to work so I can invite
people over for a stream but it's it's
been giving me some problems since it's
a it's not a clean clean there's no
clean way of doing it it's like you have
to do workarounds thanks a lot Ben Ross
ex Julio s versus Jana stem yah Aniston
alright he's going for the h7 pawn and
we should definitely consider Bishop f5
this would be winning yeah he goes for
it so yeah okay first we block with the
night and we don't have sufficient
attackers but yeah c3 will will fix that
so f3 will fix that
thanks a lot Allah Noah for the
contribution chest yes chest is the
meaning of life definitely
yeah Marco it's not the rakia man if I
if I did rocky on streams we would it
would go you know it would just go wrong
can I show a game between starfish and
alpha were stock fish wins
no I already explained this plenty of
times a lot of people are just you know
oh no stock fish is better no stock fish
you know they say alpha was playing on a
much better hardware that but none of
that actually matters they just wanted
to see can alpha learn to play and
that's all they wanted to know not if
alpha will actually beat stock fish if
they wanted offer to beat stock fish
they would just let off train again
stock fish and they would basically they
would create a stock fish killer and
then alpha could beat stock fish maybe
90 games out of a hundred but that that
wasn't the point so the reason why I'm
not so much interested in games were
stock fish defeats alpha is that the
games are not so impressive as the the
moves are engine like and it's not not
you know not mysterious and not not a
lot of fun so here black blundered but
is there a way around it
huh
he's down to eight seconds Saget
Dirigo men five seconds yeah white will
definitely enjoy this or will he how do
you continue here well you should play
something
I have I had to put a user in timeout
since since the mods aren't doing it I
had to do it myself
yeah I wasn't pleased but it had to be
done with it took revenge okay I will
have to check out the game I still
haven't seen the game but I'm sure it
made with it extremely happy okay so
let's check out how our leaders doing
huh who's leading the tournament
okay Bruno obviously Bruno is always in
the lead so let's check out Bruno's game
against the enemy 1 431 4 3 2 1 see your
subscriber since 5 K if you're a
subscriber since 5 K that means you've
seen the top 10 facts videos that's
really really really awesome
okay seriously do we really need more
mods I mean it doesn't seem like the
chat is so so you know aggressive yeah I
will remake some older videos there are
so many that should be remade but some
I'm not gonna remake like I'm never
gonna remake the the technical versus a
news medina of 1962 Soviet team
championships since its it's just III
really like it the way it is and there
are some other games like that like I
don't think I'll be doing the the mortal
game the evergreen game those really
like more few opera game can I make the
arena one hour later yeah I could but
Tarun accepts the offer to be a
moderator all right Tarun there you go
you are now a moderator let's see if if
this is now if it will work now all
right Bruno really up on the clock but
well mostly because anyway I know
berserk so let's see if Bruno will be
able to handle all the pressure tonight
captures and see three very nice so if
Queen captures Queen then you have an
in-between move very nice and if pawn
captures then it's just a weak c3 pawn
so it does make sense
no I've never traveled to India and I
think I know it will Lucent I'm here 18
seconds on the clock he just gave up his
Queen that's what happens when you when
you think about pawns for too long does
the white win every time when the chess
engine plays against itself I don't
think so
like most of the times white will win a
majority of the decisive games but not
all of them
how did Bruno play here and last
tournament I think Bruno plays every
tournament
why wouldn't he seems like seems like a
reasonable thing and Bruno wins good
game Bruno team oh god okay we have a
team agate player nice let's see how
team Agatha's against Viraj 45 someone
is asking how to participate in the in
the tournament I will I will let the
chat answer that how do you join the
tournament it's not it's not not an easy
one
yes Bruno is Bruno ISA Sasha Baron
character one of them
when will the Kasparov saga begin I
don't know I think as part is still too
young to get a saga so we'll see how
many creation GM's do I know I'm pretty
sure all of them there there aren't so
there aren't that many in Croatia yes
there is a link in the description and
team agate is is doing well I guess okay
very nice wing captures threatens mate
Oh even that why that okay it makes
sense
how will black defend against this yeah
you have to give up some material give
up the bishop oh no you're gonna do it
like that
if this rook moves it's it's game over
okay nice now this pawn is marching
forward 10 seconds left
oh it's not gonna be easy threatening
Queen g8 nope not gonna rock h1 probably
rook h1
yeah rook c7 rook c7 and it's gonna be a
flag off ah
Team Rocket loses this one but it was a
it was a good run all right who do we
have Murad leading without loss Jana
Jana SHhhh from Poland from the previous
tournament let's see how Jana she is
doing favorite comic book character I
cannot tell you because that would spoil
our our new new chess comic but from
from the existing ones
I don't know so hard to say
no English is not my first language
obviously too much mods are butchering
democracy yeah okay but we can easily
remove some mods so it's not a problem I
think for the moment for the moment
we're doing okay Jana Jana really really
going for material here with his King
and c7 going for some artificial
castling and it's only move eleven like
it does look like we're deep into the
game but it's movie eleven
yeah I like so many movies I couldn't
pick a favorite one like no way
I'm a big fan of the of the Groundhog
Day yeah Groundhog Day that's that's a
good movie so Bill Murray and can
remember who who also is in it Goverdhan
booray thanks a lot thanks for the
contribution I will continue doing it
hopefully all right so that King still
on c7 and that night can come to e6
which would be very unpleasant but other
than that yeah I guess maybe push the
pawn check when's the Queen makes sense
now there's the threat of just this so
we'll see if Jana Jana spots it but even
if you spot it you don't you don't have
all that much you can do
Nikola Tesla what about Nikola Tesla
okay he blocks it with the night but
still Bishop f4 very strong I guess yeah
he goes for it yep he had to do it
oh yeah and now he's the one if yeah he
found it he thought maybe now Bishop
captures and I have checked picks up the
Queen but you don't okay you are still
with the two rooks so anything can
happen
all right eise Evan yeah you can't
defend the night even if you defend yeah
okay you can defend it like that but
still yeah there's no defending the
night it will be a quick quick quick
death
all right and Janish will still try and
play this never give up that's the
spirit
who is the next GM after the nvl2 host
host on a podcast I don't know I will I
will send an invitation and who will be
interested but I might not go for for a
GM for the second podcast I might to go
for someone else maybe doing something
else in the chess world or maybe maybe
not even from the chess world at all
we'll see Janish down to ten seconds
if he wins this then anything is
possible I don't see how but there were
positions where I said that there's no
way that you can you can do anything
here and then it just you know
completely turns around so okay capture
the bishop white gets another Queen and
now Yash will try to try to get a
stalemate out of this I guess
and
if you grab the rookies stalemate yeah
he's bought it of course he will not
allow the stalemate yeah now you capture
okay so he did everything he could but
it wasn't enough we've seen that coming
Bruno dropped to two all the way to
tenth let's see how Jukka rich analysis
Jukka rich analysis I think he also he
also has a YouTube channel I think I
think so
against traveler to we're already seen
traveler how much bration money is $1 I
think last time I checked it was like $1
was like six and a half Croatian kunas
or maybe six say in between six and six
and a half
however played Quatro chess or unbound
chess no I haven't I
rarely play chess variants like if it's
not normal chess and probably will not
play it okay so same amount of pawns but
black with the possibility to create a
connected pawn there so yeah you go for
that and now three against three
with so much time on the clock so we'll
see we'll probably have a repetition in
the next three moves and oh no no we
won't
yeah of course you're just gonna ignore
him go back king d3 and then he goes
after your pawn yep white white found
the way
do I think the Redskins game annual is
better than dr. Karstens Carsten Mueller
and game encyclopedia I don't know what
the second one is but I do know what it
is in game annual and I pretty much
always recommend that one
and there's civic : thanks a lot man so
he doesn't want to go after the pawn to
allow black that kind of box him in then
after here then the F pawn drops yeah
that's the that's the beauty of King and
pawn and games can I make some content
on Leon each time games and analysis
yeah I could I know I know a great game
between Fischer and Stein that I don't
think I've covered its I even have a
book it's called the 100 best chess
games like in the second half of the
20th 21st century of the of the 20th
century and the the first game that it
starts with it's Bobby Fisher versus
Leon each time we'll pregnant and I ever
beat Alireza
well if they both continue progressing
and playing chess it's a good chance of
course yes
oh I don't know mr. truth mr. truth says
that you you were put in time to time
out for no reason
I'm gonna have to check on that I don't
know I don't really the sense I don't
know who my mods are there's no like
like an audition for a mod yes there is
a possibility they are using overusing
their power but that's why we have new
mods in every stream some are some are
from the previous stream of course but
you can't predict such things I look
like mr. bean thanks a lot man no I'm
not from Zagreb no but we're very close
sir give thinking thanks a lot man
thank you for the contribution all right
let me just check ok wild Indian is
joining us let's see let me just check
if Philip is playing okay he has a he's
in an end game queen against two rooks
let's see how Filipina does against even
Ivana soon oh one no I've never been to
Israel
yeah I've also I also gotten that plenty
of times that I look like Mike Boyd even
though I have no idea who that is
what are my thoughts and Chinese
crushing the the online tournament well
nothing much I mean it's kind of to be
expected I mean the I don't know if
they're officially the top team but I'm
pretty sure they are like they are the
top-rated team so it's not really not
really a surprise here Philip with two
points against three yeah not gonna not
gonna do it
ah that's my boy he does challenges and
a SC it looks at if he can become good
at it in a month okay I'm gonna check it
out
her mother says this channel isn't that
bad
thanks a lot man that's that's that's
definitely something and now he will
grab the pawn and that's it can you
check mate with a knight and the bishop
yes it's one of the one of the best
checkmates
all right good game not not your not
your game Filipino is the wild Indian
playing we haven't seen his game and
he's already in second place so we'll
we'll have to see how it goes
all right 1500 players so far not bad
all right we get to see the game by mr.
wild Indian can I do a collab with Ana
Rudolph I think I think she doesn't
really do all that all that much chess
anymore she's now I think she does
videos on like motivational stuff and
other games and choker and stuff like
that
ah ha ha good matter with night odds or
Morphy I I don't know I I like myself
with night odds
well I've never enjoyed English opening
I've never played it myself but it does
seem like like you can get a good game
playing it we did try it against Anand
in the some some a rhino's video and we
we did well so maybe it's not not the
worst I just I just never gave it any
serious thought
bangala thanks a lot man all right
what's happening here with the with the
wild Indian and a th for for one so a
nice nice Sicilian we're we're we're
white being Carol both bishops on the
Kings side and we'll see how it goes
yeah we definitely want to remove your
rook and hopefully get your Bishop into
the game you might might go b6 and that
should be seven but we'll see
are there any positive sides and cross
and opening switching places of king and
queen yeah there's a positive side you
will get you will get a lot of use if
you do that and also bragging rights if
you beat someone with that but actual
positive sides no I do not play Empire
Earth or Age of Empires but I did play
it you know a long long time ago
Xavier Barton yeah I quit League for
good pretty much I do I do install it
every year and play a few games but then
I also remember why I stopped playing it
so I can't abandon it but but arum
sometimes I will play a game of harem
just you know for fun
broodwar what do you mean by brood war
starcraft brood war
all right 94 that's a good square for
the night not a lot of ways to kick it
away and black still yeah you can't
really do anything with the bishop since
the knife yeah okay now that the knight
moves then maybe you can go for Bishop
e7 yeah that's the the joys of playing
the Sicilian
yeah I've seen void boys video about
about the current situation League what
was over boys one of the first people i
i followed on youtube actually was a
long time ago back in back in season two
of league ah there's no it wouldn't do
you any good if i increase the time in
slow mode since it's not the same people
over and over asking questions it's a
lot of people so slow mode will not
really do that yeah yeah i own a ps4
like i mentioned i use it for for
enjoying final fantasy 7 the remake
yes I've been to Germany plenty plenty
of times do I get bored frustrated by
playing and following chess every day
not really it's what I've been doing for
for like forever
Marco there you go you are now a mod
yeah the remake is harder definitely but
you can also just switch it to the easy
mode the story mode and then the fights
are really simple I still play it in
hard mode but if it will take me too
much time I'm definitely gonna switch
alright so for points against for black
is coming for him oh that's a pawn
everything gets traded off and yeah it's
two against two
rockin game we're gonna have a flag off
check you lose that one black up upon
but that's there's no way to win this
unless you okay unless you're up a rock
I was gonna say unless you win the flag
war but being off a rock will also work
so let's see if he can do it with seven
seconds on the clock which technique
will he use yeah you have to shift the
King over there oh this is this is
intense and that's it alright he did it
you should always you should learn how
to do this because if you play bullet
and the time on the clock is low you
will probably not be able to do it so
you should you should practice it you
know bring the friend challenge him wait
for ton time to run out with only rook
and King on the board and then try and
do it against your friend or against the
computer so you don't have to do all
that but still in the lead followed by
Bruno Party which in second place are
new in third and wild Indian who lost
his first game as he blundered the rook
drops the fourth place that was a tough
tough break for him creative genius okay
but let's check out some some people who
are not so high up the board as we still
have plenty of time
precision versus accuracy all right
let's see if he's precise and accurate
did I win the fantasy for Magnus
Invitational no I haven't as I chose
ding to win and then he just blundered
everything against Magnus okay I will
increase the slow mode to 20 seconds
there we go
you've talked me into it will I cover
the newest Svidler versus Carlson match
I know it's pretty much everything about
that is said everything is set whittler
commented on it well said its are you
talking about the one like oh no you
bastard you horrible person wherever he
goes for the h5 rosalie mo that that one
yeah no it's a bit too too short
the London system I've tried playing it
and it does seem to win me more games
than by playing efore so I might switch
who knows who knows alright Bishop f5
victory boy chess Victor Boyce's will I
cover Alireza versus Aragon I think I've
seen the game but still haven't decided
whether to cover it or not let me just
check something really quickly
all right everything is everything is
going well Queen before so now where
does the Queen go
any retirement age for chess I don't
know like 30
but no I don't think there is as long as
you're able to keep up I'm pretty sure
you're gonna you're gonna be able to
play honor being the the proof of that
yeah retirement age of chess equals
death that is well said we will return
to the morphe saga whenever we return I
have no idea precision versus accuracy
yes it was precise and accurate but
lacked a bit of speed so he loses on
time it's unfortunate but good game
Victor boy chess how are we doing here
okay doing well let's check up on some
other games Hinkey kingmaker let's let's
look for a game that's just starting out
maybe okay this one side G versus Donald
[Music]
[Music]
ah then I'll berserk okay seems like
yeah seemed like he was the way to low
on time Rocky kicks and bakes thanks a
lot man further a job of be allowed to
clear the candidates I have no idea
seems like it would be fair towards him
but not at the expense of points from
other players as you know players who
are already leading it would just be you
know they are already they already did
wrong towards the job of so doing wrong
towards other players doesn't really fix
that but yeah there I I really I really
like to be the idea someone had like a
little jog of play online against
everyone else and then when the
tournament starts over you just start
from the second half with our job of
already played there against everyone in
the tournament just continues with
everyone having a rest day every every
day now so that's one way to do it but
it would mean that we would have nine
players in the candidates which is which
is weird but everything else shifted due
to the coronavirus so maybe wouldn't be
a terrible idea for for that switch as
well
how come stock fish missed the line in
an ins game stock which didn't miss the
line
thanks summer true for the contribution
but you just have to allow it to run
deeper I think Nippo mentioned that
black is already lost after Bishop to e6
so you don't even have to wait for d4 to
allow white to push a5 and sacrifice the
bishop if you allow the engine to crunch
the numbers long enough already at
Bishop d6 it's lost
have I ever opened with f4 yeah I have
sometimes it's it's actually a useful
trick if you like playing the Kings
gambit but no one replies with e5 then
maybe you can go f4 and then people go
for the gambit c5 and then you just
switch with e4 and then you get to play
the Kings gambit or you can just capture
the pond if you like playing that
hm
[Music]
all right and the dental losses but it
was very hard at the pond prevents him
from coming to g5 since he did berserk
but you know that that happens in chess
when you berserk what do we have who do
we have here
Tracey ology madness boy 21 what's
happening here
okay a nice closed game with Queens and
rooks on the board that's that's always
always fun
watch our motto jump around music video
what's what's another matter jump run
music video now haven't haven't seen
that
do I like the Evans gambit no it's snot
not the greatest you know there are much
better openings so it's just not safe
did I know there's a Wikipedia page
about me yeah I did I have no idea who
made it
am i famous in Croatia now no not really
not really do I know any grandmasters
from Serbia yes
little rabbit takes a break all right 26
more minutes how are we doing here at
the top
I know it's still leading I don't even
know if we've seen a game by you anyway
I have a 1-1 against them probably
bullet but who knows all right we can
check out one from the start and I know
a berserks
yo nosh it's very brave to preserve
someone so much higher rated that's
that's very nice there was a meme about
flashing images on you okay
I haven't seen that one I've seen one
someone posted he found in Instagram
something about something about Warcraft
memes
okay it's on uh no J Oh it'sit's uh no J
is that how you pronounce it it's an
Indian name okay
[Music]
thank you Scott Simon born when the bars
open up have a drink on me and I will I
definitely will they open up on Monday
actually here in Croatia I don't think
anyone will will go right away as you
know doesn't mean that you have to go
just because it opened up but the people
will people will go it's you know open
the bar and people will come
can I call Yann
yeah I I did call Ian but he cannot join
us now that well that this whole
coronavirus situation is going on but
when it comes down yeah I should play
someone in a bar for $30 yes
easy money
like like Joe in charge okay so it's uh
Nagy yeah I can never tell in in Indian
name so when is it a J or when is the
when is it the joy or when is it a year
like here it's uh Nagy and Samm is Samm
I so it's it's a year another J the
corona situation is pretty okay I think
Croatia is currently at 2100 confirmed
cases but I think more than a thousand
have already been been cured and yeah
like I said the bars are already opening
up on Monday so not on edge
Anuj Anuj really you're gonna I'm gonna
have to take a tutorial I'm gonna have
to take a tutorial and Indian names yeah
it's not it's not getting any better can
I invite young Gustafson for a podcast
yeah I can I actually think he would be
interested in doing a podcast but he's
over he's so busy I don't know
what's this okay
and now you wiggle wiggle your way in
with the bishop somehow okay okay so he
grabs that but now the points come
marching forward honor honor means food
in Hindi isn't Giri food in in Hindi
I've seen people writing that Giri means
food in Hindi okay that's check and now
what oh very nice very nice in black
resigns all right good good game Burger
King so much higher rated player and the
winning obviously effortlessly great job
man
I'll give his Mountain okay haha
giving means drawing Hindi yeah alright
who haven't we seen from the top ten ZB
99 from Italy okay
is is your game starting yeah I've seen
Magnus posted a video he posted the
video on his game his first game as a
world champion against Boris Gelfand
yeah I haven't seen the video Bruno you
already lost oh man what happened oh
so that's that's that's a shame
all right let's check up some other guys
I am mate
checkmate from Poland okay mate
checkmate from Poland
do most of the names in India mean
something or is it just like in chess
whenever there's an Indian name someone
mentions oh yeah that of course means
that so are like most of the names do
that do they mean something Giri also
means unknot okay yeah there are those
there those funny videos and tik-tok
about languages that like in French like
the word there's like this word and then
it means a lot of different stuff in
French but if you don't speak French
everything sounds the same and I've seen
it today they've been doing it with
other languages as well so it seemed
very very interesting okay so obviously
giri means a lot of things from ranging
from mountain to food to to a nut
I should invite Magnus to a podcast yeah
but he's so busy so who knows maybe
maybe someday Leyla means play in Hindi
okay I'm gonna learn a lot of Hindi
words yes who is the the most colorful
chess player that is that is a good
question but I'm pretty sure everyone
knows the answer to that all right
I'm I'm mate checkmate that's a that's a
very nice-looking passed pawn but it's
not going to be easy and with the rook
hmm okay with the bishop and he's down a
rook will erase a be a world champion
someday others a there's a chance of
course but it's hard to say in bulletin
even bullied and Blitzen rapid like
anything can happen like his his you
know it could go well but then again it
could go incredibly wrong and in
classical well you you first have to
qualify for the candidates and then then
it just gets even harder
Abraham how to contact me well you can
contact me via Twitter like I do I do
accept messages on Twitter that's what I
mostly check so yeah that's good that
will
yeah truth I think they I think they put
you in timeout because you copy/paste
the same question over and over I don't
know
sorry I haven't checked but yeah
do do lighten up a bit and the
moderators don't don't ban people for
four nice questions you don't really you
can still join the tournament of course
it's it's still early but it will be
finished in some 16 minutes so divakaran
nothing going on here okay we've seen
most of the games by them capper born
okay let's see caper born from USA who
is also Alicia's patron against Jukka
rich analysis
what what's it mean the the best Hindi
word to learn what's it mean but ban
child okay
and now you attack the rook and you win
the exchange okay
make sense I had to swear word yeah
someone tricked me
someone tricked me then I thought it
might be a trick but I thought nad they
wouldn't do it but they did
all right so the rooks still hanging on
its what what is this why is that a free
okay that's weird
did I miss something it seemed like a
free rook yes I got trolled yeah I
decided not to participate in these
tournaments since I wanted to show
well basically give a given opportunity
to subscribers to have their own games
on the channel and everyone else is just
you know playing tournaments so I
decided to mix it up and show subscriber
games instead but when I will make like
a day of it let's say sometimes when I
will have more time when I finish with
this whole now I'm too busy pretty much
to do anything with with preparing the
podcast and and the manga going on and
obviously making videos every day but
when it all you know calms down a bit
then then we'll do more streams where I
will be accepting challenges and we can
play some nice games can people with a
rating of 700 play there yeah yeah they
can everyone can play doesn't doesn't
matter your your rating
all right Rock f1 and now you move the
bishop and you start grabbing those
those pawns yup he goes for it and now
root okay check and he resigns yeah make
sense there was nothing to be done there
good game Kappa born let's check out
Goran chess lab is here all right let's
check out his game if he is still
playing against part revenge
uh-huh should there be a title above GM
yeah I think there should as I wouldn't
say there are too many gyms but the the
bar has been lowered and either I would
say a few leader raised the for it to be
like 25 50 or maybe even 2600 or allow
for a super Grandmaster title or
something like that it wouldn't really
change anything everything would be
exactly the same as before but it would
maybe motivate those who are even even
further up top in in the chess chess
elite world to try harder to grab that
title
yeah super GM is the thing that
sometimes we can use to describe someone
who's let's say in the top top 30 maybe
of the world but it's not officially a
thing where you will be able to purchase
see the manga it will be available on
the website that is currently being
being developed and it will be free you
will not have to purchase it so it's
gonna be free for everyone but you will
have options of supporting supporting
the idea if you if you think it's it's a
good idea and the end if you enjoyed of
course Magnus is the only super GM now
yeah
all right so two against one and the
black will be very happy just pushing
this pawn so white will try to prevent
something okay yeah makes sense
good game good game there's no getting
out of this one yep
good game by Gordon chess lab defeating
spark revenge ten more minutes in the
tournament let's see
praying mantis is praying mantis a pray
or praying all right Knight captures and
g2 immediately we have action
mmm-hmm Queen g3 okay and make sense
capture the bishop and that's game yeah
if pawn captures if pawn captures you
have this check wins the Queen or I'm
missing something
your favorite in the candidate I don't
have any in the candidates tournament
but I would like to see em BL or or nepo
challenge Magnus for some for some super
interesting games I thought we would see
ding like crushing everyone but he just
had a really bad start but I'm kinda I
do can think that it had something to do
with all of this coronavirus situation
as he he just wasn't playing as he
usually does it was just it was a bit
weird have engines ruined chess or
improved it well first they improved
that then they really ruined it
they really made it boring but now with
neural networks surfacing I think we're
gonna see a lot of well improvements
like Carlson's h5 or Salim oh that might
be might be pretty great
Nagaraju Gupta thank you for the
contribution the only game that cannot
be stopped by any virus is chess there
you have it there you have it ladies and
gentlemen can stop which defeat alpha
zero no no one can defeat alpha unless
alpha chooses otherwise yes I've never
thought about making a chess channel
where I speaking Croatian as it would it
would have a very very few viewers
favorite tournament of all time
well the of course everyone knows that
the the 1959 candidates tournament no I
don't think as part of lives in Croatia
all the time
he has Croatian citizenship but he's not
here all the time
and we have a win by praying mantis that
was a that was a very nice attack all
right seven more minutes let's see how
are we doing at the top uh Nagy is it a
nudge all right let's see another game
by our leader who is crushing everyone
soon too is soon who is really coming
for him all right so we had a we had a
berserk here but it's gonna be it's
gonna be crazy
opposite colored bishops with this past
pawn already here yeah
black will have to give up the roof now
or no yeah he will
there's no way no way around it oh no
he's not gonna even grab the pawn ok so
it was a good chance to try and try and
maybe triangle flagging mode but doesn't
look like it maybe he can still get a
stalemate we'll see
all right and good stuff good stuff you
can still go here so obviously you
resign another win for the leader and
let's see who is coming for him soon sue
is on a really awesome unbeaten streak
but I don't think he has chances of
reaching the top
however smashed the board after losing a
game no but I know people who have
[Music]
can I beat Alexandra botas I've never
played against her I don't have any
plans to visit India India India but I
would definitely plan to visit
did I ever rage quit a chess game of
course I don't I don't think there's a
person who hasn't
what's Queen d1
what's Queen D one Queen D 1 is OK and
now captures and then okay
what's next for the Murphy saga well we
we continue where we left off
he's currently facing Boden and after
that he will face mr. Barnes the
legendary mr. Barnes and then we
continue oh that's that was that was bad
alright so blade black mix makes it he
doesn't get checkmated and he just needs
to survive a little bit longer okay he
goes there so 12 more min 12 more
seconds can he do it yeah white is
trying but he just has everything
covered
alright 8 seconds and now white we'll
just have to accept that there is no way
around this check and mate yeah he's
gonna he's gonna try and okay it's not
possible but why not put those pawns Wow
Wow
okay this is too much yeah there's a
there's a reason why you should never
give up yep
and soon to get gets flagged Wow that
was that was the best ever game so good
stuff alright it's coming home
let's see a game I don't think we've
seen it longest thinking time before
making a move in a classical game I
think it was over an hour for one move I
knew Sharma probably probably after the
Nations Cup we're gonna cover that game
what did the Queen and g7 tell the King
and g8 hi mate okay it's coming home
against a th for for one okay pawns are
coming forward both where's Burger King
and now you want to shift the bishop
over there okay oh there goes the pawn
that's shame
very interesting
and that's mate
the pond prevents the king from escaping
very nice good game ATH for for one
let's check out even ESCO if he is
playing it doesn't seem like it ah but
it's 20 seconds more in the tournament
yeah favorite player of all time the
chat already answered that but I'm
pretty sure they can do it again who's
the next biggest thing I don't know
we'll see there are so many so many
players like I don't know abdul Sattar
of noted bet he is it's hard to say he's
very young but he had a really good shot
against uh for example Carson in the in
the world blitz championship all right
so the that's it for the other matters
Friday arena so meadow arena finished
with chess world
16:12 a new era 1000 and egged ruined
drunken Stein winning and in the argon
matter Friday arena I believe this is
the fourth edition we have announced a
one four three two winning first place
with a performance of 2022 86 and win
rate of 69% and a hundred percent
berserk rate there you have it in order
to win you must berserk second place a
th 4 for 1 with a performance of 20 605
that's pretty insane with a win rate of
89% in berserk rate of 42 percent and
it's coming home with a performance of
2345 76% win rate and 71 percent berserk
rate so not bad and our top 10 are on
aside from those three Janish mb in fort
Bruno pasture which congrats Bruno in
fifth Sun Tzu in sixth CB in seventh
fede master wild Indian from Russia in
eighth traveler - in ninth and fede
master Madhavi from Slovenia in 10th and
the list goes on Cape aborn test to test
overture ITP v r IG good ol one Goren
chest lab in 15 Afghan physicists the
fast in sixteen vardas who was leading
pretty much for the entire event its
17th Daniel C 87 in 1870 in 19 and T
Margot in 20
ok we made it Sam now that's it for this
week's Argonauts Friday arena I'll see
you guys next Friday and I'm publishing
now the video now Hari Krishna vs. Jorge
Cory if you haven't seen it in the
Nations Cup it will be available like
maybe in the in the next five minutes so
do check that out as well so that's the
tournament and the stream I do hope you
enjoyed it and see you guys soon thanks
for thanks for joining in